milquetoast mayor Pete vu de jedge got a
standing ovation during a Fox News
townhall over the weekend but the polls
put Joe Biden at a commanding lead over
every candidate not just the Democrats
that includes president Trump we examine
what the polls will tell us about
conservatism from the u.s. to Europe all
the way to Australia then the media
pretend that men can get pregnant and
anti Trump Republican humiliates himself
and revenge porn tests the limit of
politics I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the first show I think in a week
where we're not talking about making
babies we you know there was all of
those stories the laws out of Alabama
Georgia Louisiana Missouri last week all
about making babies today is the first
time that we will move on we won't talk
about it except for this one thing we
should we should mention speaking of
making babies some things are
uncomfortable to talk about sex is one
of those things but sex is one of the
most important things in life it is so
so great especially within the context
of marriage
studies show seventy percent of guys who
experienced a rectal dysfunction don't
get treated for it just for that reason
because it's extremely awkward and you
don't want to have to go to the pharmacy
counter and say hey can I get some pills
to fix that problem that I don't want to
talk about listen it's nothing to be
ashamed about just like many many health
issues or not anything to be ashamed
about that's where our friends at Roman
come in thankfully Roman created an easy
way to get checked out by a doctor and
get treated for IDI on line with a Roman
you can get medical care for IDI if
appropriate from the comfort and privacy
of your own home you don't need to worry
about that awkward conversation with the
pharmacist at the store you handle
everything online in a convenient
discreet manner getting started is
simple just go to get Roman comm slash
Noel's cane or wles and complete an
online visit if your doctor decides that
treatment would be appropriate they can
prescribe genuine medication that can be
delivered in discreet packaging right to
your door I emphasize discreet packaging
I know you're worried fellas don't worry
about it free two-day shipping guys go
to the doctor erectile dysfunction can
be tough to tackle but it is really
important to get checked out with Roman
it's easy to connect to a doctor get
Roman comm / Noel's K no W le s get a
free online visit free two-day shipping
get Roman comm / Knolls for a free visit
to get started what's that address you
heard it get Roman comm / Knolls who
says we're not pro life on this show
we're pro life beginning to end has Joe
Biden already won the 2020 race I'm not
even just talking about the primary I'm
talking about the whole election right
now the Real Clear Politics average so
there are all these different polls Real
Clear Politics comes in creates the
average of all the polls
has Joe Biden at 38.3% Bernie Sanders
who is in second place in the Democrat
primary at 18.8% Warren at eight and a
half percent Harris at seven point three
percent Budaj edge at seven percent bado
at a pathetic three point eight percent
Booker at a still more pathetic 2.5
percent Castro down at 1.5 percent I
kind of forgot that guy was even running
not fidel not Raul who Leon Castro Club
you are at one point three percent Tulsi
Gabbard at one percent
Andrew yang at one percent Kirsten
Gillibrand of one percent and I think
like twenty other people who aren't even
registering interesting to note here all
of these people in this polling were
national figures before they ran for
president except for Pete Buddha jej and
Andrew yang but right now Peabody jej is
polling at seven times the rate of
Andrew yang so Buddha judge actually
putting up some pretty decent numbers
for a small-town mayor from the Midwest
everyone else was a national figure they
are all getting trounced by Joe Biden
and President Trump has already declared
this primary over one of my favorite
things the president Trump does is when
he acts as a political pundit for the
other side so you tweeted this ad he
said quote looks like Bernie Sanders is
history sleepy Joe Biden is pulling
ahead and think about it I'm only here
because of sleepy Joe and the man who
took him off the one-percent trash heap
that's President Obama president Oh
China once sleepy Joe badly I just love
this idea it gives me something to look
forward to that eventually in six years
when I guess no I'm not six years five
years when President Trump is out of
office that we can look forward to him
being on cable news listen these crazy
Democrats oh my goodness so he's already
done this before he did it with
Elizabeth Warren he said I think
Elizabeth Warren is finished in the race
because it turns out that I'm more
Indian that than she is and I'm zero
percent Indian but she's done so even
even President Trump right now is saying
Joe Biden is doing very well he's
already kind of talking about Joe Biden
as if he is the general election
candidate the
problem with this is that Joe Biden
isn't only beating all the other
Democrats
he's also beating President Trump in the
polls and and by a lot now you might say
well who cares if Joe Biden is beating
Trump in the national polls we don't
hold a national election we hold
presidential elections by state so all
that matters is whether Joe Biden is
beating Donald Trump in the states that
matter Pennsylvania Wisconsin Michigan
those swing states again here the
trouble is that Joe Biden is not just
leading President Trump in the polls in
those states
he's trouncing him he's up by almost 10
points in all those states in
Pennsylvania he's up by over 10 points
Biden this beating Trump for at fifty
four to forty three point five in
Michigan Biden is beating Trump fifty
three point five to forty three and in
Wisconsin he's beating Trump 54 to 46 so
an eight point lead even in Wisconsin
that is not good news for Donald Trump
and so I see why Donald Trump wants to
fight back already in the general that's
a bad idea
let the Democrats all start to kill each
other this has not even begun yet you I
mean right now we're looking at a lot of
name recognition Joe Biden has a lot of
name ID so naturally he's doing quite
well in the polls but we haven't even
had the first debate yet this hasn't
really gotten started better to let the
Democrats all duke it out themselves so
is the 2020 Democrat race over I mean is
arisen even 2020 election over they'll
do the debates will play out you'll have
multiple debates then you'll get the
nominating contest then eventually
you'll get the general election looking
at these poll numbers Trump's down by 10
in the swing states is the election over
I think Biden has three big weaknesses
now the weaknesses pose a problem when
you're running against president Trump
but they are weaknesses nonetheless
number one he's corrupt people aren't
really talking about this story but he's
corrupt number two
he's a liar and a bloviator he lies a
lot and he always exaggerated
number three he's been in government
forever and he hasn't done very much
though
the three weaknesses corruption lies in
effectiveness now what's the trouble the
trouble is if you say he's corrupt then
what are you gonna point to you point to
the business deals the shady sketchy
unfair business deals that his son got
in China and the Ukraine in China Joe
Biden's son hunter Biden got his his
private equity firm got a 1 billion
dollar deal with the Chinese government
this is according to investigative
journalist Peter Schweitzer who is
hunter Biden it's not Beau Biden Beau
Biden is Joe Biden's son who died
tragically a brain cancer a few years
ago hunter Biden is the other son and
hunter is basically an influence peddler
he's counselor counsel at Boys schiller
which is a Democrat law firm he set up a
few front companies one called Rosemont
and he's just petals influence he's not
peddling his own influence because he's
never held public office he was peddling
his father's influence and so while Joe
Biden as a vice president of the United
States was negotiating with the Chinese
hunter Biden's firm received a 1 billion
dollar private equity deal with the
government this later increased to 1.5
billion dollars according to Peter
Schweitzer when did that deal happen
that deal came through hours before Vice
President Biden met with the Chinese
president who Jintao in DC for a nuclear
security summit
sure looks like a crony deal to me I
mean more information will come out of
course these are all just allegations
for now but sure looks shady similar
issue in the Ukraine
so same guy hunter Biden same influence
peddler was being investigated in the
Ukraine Ukraine's top prosecutor was
looking into a money-laundering scheme
by a company called buries m'a buries
m'a on their board of directors had
hunter Biden there they were paying
hunter Biden $50,000 a month why hunter
Biden has never demonstrated any
particular skill at at anything other
than selling influence but obviously if
the guy's father is the Vice President
of the United States if the father is
the point person on UK
ukrane issues with the United States
maybe it would behoove certain actors in
the Ukraine to pass over 50 G's a month
to Hunter Biden in the hope that some
favorable treatment would come from the
United States now the top prosecutor in
Ukraine was investigating this
money-laundering scheme and at that time
Vice President Biden insisted that the
prosecutor be removed from office
so Biden point guy on Ukraine he goes in
he says we will withhold 1 billion
dollars from Ukraine if this prosecutor
is not fired and you don't need to just
take my word for it you don't need to
worry that I'm some conspiracy theorist
because of Joe Biden is so gaffe prone
he actually managed to brag about this
crooked deal at the Council on Foreign
Relations areas
I guess the 12th 13th time to Kiev and
and I was going supposed to announce
that there was another billion dollar
loan guarantee and I had gotten a
commitment from poroshenko and from
yachts and hook that they would take
action against the state prosecutor and
they didn't so they said they had it
they were walking out to press kind of
said no I said I'm not going or we're
not going to give you the billion
dollars they said you have no authority
you're not the president the president
said I said call him I said I'm telling
you're not getting a billion dollars I
said you're not getting a billion I'm
gonna be leaving here I think it was
about six hours I looked I said believe
in six hours if the prosecutors not
fired you're not getting the money well
son of them got fired and they put in
place someone who was solid at the time
people knock Trump for sounding like a
mobster when he talks you know we're
gonna end Iran you're gonna do this this
guy's a killer this guy's a shark Joe
Biden there sounds like a mobster said
yeah I went over to Ukraine I had all my
influence I had a billion dollars of
taxpayer money on the table I said
you're not getting a billion unless you
fire that guy that I don't like who's
looking into my son's company and they
say to me you can't make that decision I
says to him I says listen to what I says
to him I says call up the president
you're not getting a billion dollars do
what I say fire that prosecutor who
looking he's looking a little too close
getting a little too big for his
britches over there looking into my
son's company all right guess what
happened
son of a gun the guy gets fired how
about that he's bragging about it like
Tony Soprano so there is very legitimate
corruption
now why would Joe brag about this is it
just cuz he's a total idiot possibly the
other reason it seems is maybe he wants
to get in front of the store he wants to
frame the story in a way that might be
somewhat favorable to him you know Joe
Biden's whole career is ingratiating
himself to people right this is why he
got in trouble for smelling hair and
giving back massages and putting his
forehead on another person's forehead I
don't think it's cuz he's a sexual
predator I think it's because he is a
slick oily politician whose entire skill
is getting people to like him but behind
the scenes he's working he's working
angles his son is cashing in on his
father's influence he's a politician
he's been in office for a very long time
so you could you could knock Joe Biden
on being corrupt the issue is if you go
after Joe Biden for being corrupt then
they're just gonna go after Donald Trump
for being corrupt and it's worth noting
there is not really a comparison here
there is no evidence of any sort of
public corruption that President Trump
is engaged in well president even close
to the scale of what joe biden is
bragging about in that clip however
Donald Trump has bragged about his
corruption of the political process
before he was president well he was
running for president he said for so
many years I bought off politicians he
joked about it when Rand Paul was going
after him during the 2016 primary he
said you know it's funnier and I
remember you coming to me and asking for
money and I wrote you that check huh I'm
the puppet master right I'm the guy
who's running things he said the way he
excuse donating to Democrats is he said
I was a real estate developer in New
York I had to buy off politicians of
both parties that's just how politics
works so if you go after Biden for
corruption they're gonna go after him
speaking of real estate in New York if
you're developing real estate in New
York you are almost by definition in
some way working with the mob so they'll
go after him they'll say he's literally
working with the mobsters so I just
think that angle is going to end up
becoming impotent it's
not going to really go anywhere so okay
you can't go after him for being corrupt
you can go after him for being a liar
which we'll get to in a second but don't
forget hiring used to be hard you
remember how hard it was you'd have all
these multiple job sites stacks of
resumes coming in especially when you're
hiring people in Hollywood you get
stacks of resumes you just throw them in
the trash it's a very confusing review
process today hiring can be easy and you
only have to go to one place to get it
done zip recruiter comm slash Knowles KO
wles you know half of the country right
now is trying to hire a new president
imagine how much simpler it would be if
we just had zip recruiter sends your job
to over 100 of the web's leading job
boards doesn't just stop there with
their powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and invites them to apply to your job
then you've got the applications coming
in zip recruiters are already doing all
the work of inviting people over zip
recruiter then analyzes each one
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match it just takes
so much of the work that you or your HR
manager or somebody would have to do it
takes so much of that work so much of
the money that that work would cost it
just does it for you it's so effective
that four out of five employers who post
on zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the first day
right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter comm slash Knowles
canna wles
zip recruiter comm slash Knowles zip
recruiter comm slash Knowles kena wles
zip recruiter is the smartest way to
hire so you can't go after and and don't
hire Joe Biden by the way please don't
hire that's it just as my personal
editorial you can go after Joe Biden on
his corruption but they're gonna go
after Trump on corruption so the next
one is you can go after Joe Biden on his
lies and Joe Biden tells some pretty
horrifying lies again this has not been
covered by the mainstream media
I bet very few people would be able to
recall this if you ask them on the
street we know some of Joe Biden's basic
lies we know that when he ran in 1988
for president he was chased out of the
race for plagiarism and for lying about
his a cadet
make record we know in 2012 when he was
vice president that he lied about Mitt
Romney he was before an entire
auditorium full of black voters and he
said Mitt Romney wants to put y'all back
in Chains pretty shameless lie pretty
shameless race baiting the lie that is
really bizarre and and really pretty
scary is that Joe Biden has actually
lied about the tragic death of his wife
and daughter and he's demonstrably lied
about it and it's been sporadically
called out by the mainstream media but
people let him get away with this really
weird
so decades ago Joe Biden's wife and
daughter were tragically killed in a car
accident
his wife Neela and his daughter Naomi
his sons Bo and Hunter were both in the
car as well they were injured but they
had luckily survived how did that car
accident happen it's because mrs. Biden
was driving she drove into a busy
intersection and unfortunately she was
in the path of an oncoming truck and the
truck hit the car so what happened here
there was an investigation at the time
the investigators found that the driver
of that truck
Curtis Dunn was blameless it was just a
horrible accident but he didn't cause it
it wasn't it wasn't through his
negligence or some criminal wrongdoing
that this accident happened it was just
an awful accident awful car accidents
happen all the time
doesn't make it any less sad or tragic
but he didn't do anything wrong the
driver okay apparently this guy by the
way Curtis Dunn carried this weight with
him until 1999 he talked about it all
the time this awful guilt that he
carried him over the course of the
decades Joe Biden started to embellish
the story of the death of his wife and
daughter so much so that he just came to
lie about it so over the years what Joe
Biden would start to do is portray the
driver is a drunk driver he said about
this poor guy Curtis Dunn quote he
allegedly drank his lunch instead of
eating his lunch then he said he was an
errant driver who stopped to drink where
did this story come from Eve even the
Atlantic and left-wing outlet
admitted that this was just a total lies
with the Atlantic road quote the family
of the truck driver has labored to
correct the record but Biden made the
reference to drunkenness as recently as
2007 needlessly resurrecting a false and
painful accusation now you'll notice
something else there when you mentioned
2007 one explanation for this is that
Joe Biden is just so full of anger over
the death of his wife and daughter he
hasn't been able to forgive the driver
he's so full of some denial about the
accidental nature of it that he's just
convinced himself of this and it's a
coping mechanism and that would be
understandable not I mean it would raise
a lot of questions about his judgment
and his fitness for office but it would
at least be understandable accept this
lie about his wife and daughter's death
tends to just come up around election
time so he's bringing this up apparently
to gain political advantage that's
pretty disgusting that's pretty awful
one because of the memory of what
happened and two because you're you as a
major public figure in the United States
a very important person given the public
trust or baselessly defaming a guy who
was involved in an accident that he's
carried guilt around for for decades
that's pretty bad stuff and I of course
the family wants to correct the record
if you've got a guy who would be the
President of the United States smearing
your family member as a drunk driver who
through negligence killed his wife and
daughter when you know that didn't
happen when there was a full
investigation and you know for a fact it
didn't happen that's pretty awful that's
that's it's pretty low stuff a bizarre
and a shameless lie okay so you could go
after Joe Biden on that front could call
him lyin Joe instead of sleepy Joe or
something like that however if you go
after Joe Biden is a liar what are they
gonna do they're gonna go after Donald
Trump as a liar
Donald Trump for playing fast and loose
with the facts again as far as I can
tell Donald Trump has told a lot of lies
Donald Trump has made a lot of false
statements he has never made a false
statement
so pathological so bizarre so low and
shameless
that one as far as I can tell it
actually when Donald Trump lies they
they tend to be less tragic and more
fantastical so when Donald Trump lies he
he suggests that Ted Cruz's father
murdered JFK which you know I mean it I
would if I were Ted Cruz I would be
upset about that but it's so outlandish
that you sort of just have to laugh at
it right there's nothing it's not like
you're painting some guy is a drunk
driver for killing your wife and
daughter well how about when he said
that he spent years talking about the
Obama birth certificate thing again 'men
son true but also it doesn't really
matter Barack Obama would have been a US
citizen even if he had been born in
Kenya because he received citizenship at
the time of birth from his mother so
it's just a kind of weird outlandish lie
that he would tell okay now again if you
hit Joe Biden for the lies they're gonna
go after Donald Trump you can try to
explain the difference between the lies
it's probably not going to land it's
probably too subtle for a general
election so then you just get to the
third weakness that Joe Biden has which
is that he's been in government forever
and he hasn't accomplished anything this
I think is a great area I think this
should be all the focus of the Trump
reelection campaign if Joe gets the
nomination Joe Biden has been in
government for 50 years he's been in
government for half a century he's been
in politics since he was 26 years old
and now I think he's a hundred and
seventy-five years old maybe I didn't do
that math right but he's been in
government forever
what has he accomplished can can you
name any major piece of legislation that
Joe Biden gets credit for any major
national initiative any major problem
solved because of Joe Biden no he's just
kind of been there he's he's also a
loser I mean he ran for president in
1988 thirty years ago and he lost then
he ran for president in 2008 20 years
after that fact and he lost and he would
have gone nowhere except that Barack
Obama hated Hillary Clinton enough to
make you abide in his vice president
he's never accomplished anything
contrast that with Donald Trump Donald
Trump has been in politics for what
three and a half years now and he's had
the most effective record of any
president in my lifetime on the right or
the left the Heritage Foundation pointed
out in 2017 2018
Donald Trump has affected a conservative
agenda more quickly even than Ronald
Reagan that's pretty good and you
remember this was a major theme in 2016
Trump talked about there are all talk no
action politicians and then there are
people like me who are action we're
developers we're builders were
businessmen that is I think the way to
go after Joe Biden and I think it's
pretty devastating because no matter how
generic Joe Biden looks no man you look
so good in a suit he's got a good smile
okay you've got name recognition are
people really gonna pick that a guy
who's never accomplished anything over
the guy who's delivered solid economy
record low unemployment relative peace
abroad I just I don't think the race is
over
I don't think Joe Biden has a nomination
locked up even the New York Times Jill
philipovich writing in The Times today
had this great headline does anybody
actually want Joe Biden to be president
no people would would tolerate him I
guess he's probably everybody's number
two choice he's doing well in the polls
with name IDs basically unobjectionable
but does anyone really want him to be
President it doesn't seem so
also remember at this point in 2016 who
were the top GOP contenders you probably
don't remember this but during the 22:16
election and I guess late 2015 the top
contenders were drumroll please
Jeb Bush Marco Rubio and Scott Walker
have they how are they doing now
Rubio is still in the Senate at least
the other two guys aren't anywhere near
the government anything could happen I
mean these polls don't tell us a whole
lot and when you see when you see people
polling at a low level but
they've kind of surged they've they've
kind of made a name for themselves like
Buddha judge you start to wonder if this
race is gonna start looking radically
different dude a judge was in a Town
Hall last night at Fox News the
supposedly conservative outlet and he
got a standing ovation we'll explain how
that happened we'll get to adjust in a
mosh the anti Trump Republican who's
calling for impeachment and then we'll
get to revenge porn if we have time but
if you want to make it all the way to
revenge porn you've got to go to Delhi
fire calm it's ten bucks a month $100
for an annual membership you get me you
get the end relieve and sure you get the
Ben Shapiro show you get the Matt Walsh
show you get to ask questions in the
mailbag coming up on Thursday you get to
ask questions backstage you get the
leftist here's tumblr that's the main
thing that you need this is what you
want you need the oh yeah that's good
that is a 2020 primary that is going to
be bruising and brutal and it hasn't
even started yet go to daily wire calm
we'll be right back with a lot more
you know it just occurs to me I think
maybe the Trump campaign has a sense
that the only way they can really go
after Biden is on his effectiveness cuz
you know they don't they're not calling
him lyin Joe they're not calling him
corrupt Joe or crooked Joe they're
calling him sleepy Joe I told you I said
sleepy Joe it's a little weird I wonder
why they're going after that in part
it's to contrast Don a Donald Trump has
much more energy than Joe Biden and
that'll be clearer on a debate stage in
part it's because it rhymes with creepy
Joe which is another one of his
nicknames so you can get that evoking
the creepy sense but I think a lot of it
is he's been in politics for 50 years
what is he done he's basically just
slept he's been asleep at the wheel he
hasn't done anything he's just this
lethargic guy who's just kind of there I
wonder if that somehow plays into it
maybe not at a conscious level but I
think there might be a sense that the
way to go after Joe is on the fact that
he's never done anything
now Budaj Edge is surging Budaj edge
mayor Pete from Indiana from South Bend
did this Fox News Town Hall he was
roundly criticized for it by the left
they didn't want them going on Fox News
the awful evil conservative Network and
guess what happened did the awful evil
conservatives kill him did they
batter him do they tar and feather him
no they gave him a standing ovation here
is what we're trying to do here is
different because the moment that we're
in is different I get that a millennial
Midwestern mayor is not what leaps to
mind when you think about a prototypical
candidate for president but I also think
we're living on ammo if it's hard to
figure out what's going on right now
it's because we are living on one of
those blank pages in between chapters in
American history and what comes next
could be ugly or it could be amazing and
I believe running for office is an act
of hope and so is voting for somebody
and supporting somebody and volunteering
for somebody I hope you'll join me in
making sure that that next era is better
than any that we've had so far
you'll see they all go up and they stand
for him they give him a standing ovation
at the Fox News Town Hall you hear them
saying Pete Pete Pete Pete they're
chanting his name so a few quick
takeaways here one Pete Budaj edge is
many multiples more intelligent than any
other Democrat in the race he's a liar
he's a radical he's a leftist sure
nevertheless he's much smarter than them
he holds himself better he speaks better
he thinks better he is much smarter than
they are the other takeaway is Fox News
is not just the conservative Network I
know that there's this idea in the
public sphere that Fox is just the
right-wing hardcore conservative network
I go on Fox News frequently I go on once
or twice a week at least and I'm a
conservative that's true they also have
a lot of left wingers own they it's true
they have some opinion people like Laura
Ingraham or Sean Hannity who are
hardcore right-wingers but they have a
ton of journalists who are central
centrist or even lean to the left and
they're a news organization they're not
just preaching to a conservative choir
they want the Democrats to come on and
so I think this helps to explain why why
did Bernie Sanders get such a great
round of applause when he was at the Fox
News townhall it's because they stacked
the audience with Bernie supporters
why did Pete buddy judge get such a
great round of applause and a standing
ovation at his Town Hall it's because
they stacked the audience with Pete
supporters and why are they doing that
they're doing that to encourage the
Democrats to come on the network that's
the only way they can get the Democrats
to come on and say listen we'll give you
really favorable coverage because and in
Fox's defense there a news organization
they don't want to be shut out of the
2020 race for all of the various
candidates the GOP already has its
candidate Donald Trump there are 23
candidates and a news organization wants
to get them on to talk about it so
that's what they're doing I don't think
this is the standing ovation is evidence
that all of a sudden middle America and
conservatives are supporting this far
left wing mayor of South Bend Indiana
but it does show you that Fox wants to
be a player in the 2020 Democrat
primary's Joe Scarborough was so
enthusiastic about this Budaj edge town
hall that over at MSNBC he actually said
that Pete Budaj single-handedly is
mainstreaming
the Democrat Party here's why see the
future of the Democratic Party and its
mayor Pete it may not be in 2020 right
perhaps it's in 2024 or beyond but this
guy is going to play an important role
in the mainstreaming the mainstreaming
of the Democratic Party for many years
to come and and believe you me that is
exactly what he does regardless of
ideology mayor Pete mainstream's a
Democratic Party I wonder whether we're
meek and I are being a bit excessive in
our praise of Mayor Pete but I've seen a
lot of candidates I think this guy I
almost called him kid yeah because he's
like 20 20 years younger than me I think
this this I think this kid is special so
just listen to that statement the
mainstreaming of the Democrat Party the
Democrat Party is the can oldest
continuously operating political party
in the world and yet they have
radicalized themselves so much that they
now need to be mainstreamed think about
how crazy that is
you've got a party that's been around
for centuries they need to be mainstream
because they've driven themselves so far
to the left Joe Biden thinks Pete's
gonna do it so let's look at Pete's
record is he gonna do it no I don't
think so I mean yeah he talks good and
he's got a nice little Midwest smile on
his face and he wears a tie with his
rolled-up shirt sleeves but he is just
as radical as all of the other
candidates he supports abortion until
birth he was asked if he supports limits
on abortion he said no he supports
reparations for the great great great
great grandchildren of black slaves in
America he supports wild conspiracy
theories even about this current
administration he talked about them last
night on Fox now you see the same thing
or something different but that same
kind of saber rattling with Iran
by the way reportedly engineered by John
Bolton who was one of the people who
built the war in Iraq how somebody who
is behind that one of the worst foreign
policy mistakes in American history is
allowed anywhere near the situation room
of a president who claims really falsely
but claims that he was against the Iraq
war all along is unbelievable to me
Iranian threats against the United
States are just being conjured up by
John Bolton I don't think that's we've
seen Iran take decisive actions against
the United States in just the last two
weeks threaten our interests in the
region that's not just imagined that's
not it's being reported in the news and
lots of different news outlets we've
seen it happen but Pete mu de jedge is
is ginning up these conspiracy theories
that that john bolton is somehow the the
puppet master of the mullahs in Iran
probably not true even worse than that
if you want to talk about radicalism
Pete Buddha judge in an interview with
Hugh Hewitt the other day on the radio
called for the renaming of memorials to
Thomas Jefferson here's why let's go to
policy now a very blunt question because
you talk about going to every Jefferson
Jackson dinner in Indiana when you're
running statewide should Jefferson
Jackson dinners be renamed everywhere
because both were holders of slaves yeah
we're doing that in Indiana I think it's
the right thing to do you know over time
you you develop and evolve on the things
you choose to honor and I think we know
enough especially after you know you
just look at what basically must be
genocide could happen here
Jefferson's more problematic at you know
there's a lot to of course admire and
thinking in his philosophy then again if
you plunge into his writings especially
the notes on the state of Virginia you
know that he knew that slavery was wrong
yeah and and yet you did it now we're
all morally conflicted human beings it's
not like we're blotting him out of the
history books you're deleting him from
being the founding fathers but now
naming something after somebody confers
a certain amount of honor and at a time
I mean the real reason I think there's a
lot of pressure on this is the
relationship between the past and the
present
listen even the language he uses he
doesn't say we're all morally broken
we're all morally fallen were all
morally imperfect he says we're all
morally conflicted you see bad guys like
Jefferson they were conflicted and they
made the bad choices but good guys like
Pete Buddha jej I mean Thomas
Jefferson's not fit to shine Pete Buddha
judges shoes right Pete Buddha judge is
a good modern guy who doesn't have
slaves Thomas Jefferson he's a bad old
guy who did have slaves so the argument
Buddha judges making is no listen we're
not blotting Jefferson out of the
history books for now we'll still let
him be in the history books but we
shouldn't honor him by naming things
after him either so we're gonna rename
the Jefferson Jackson dinner should we
also rename towns named after Thomas
Jefferson such as I don't know Jefferson
Georgia Maine New Hampshire Ohio Oregon
South Dakota Texas Wisconsin Missouri
Tennessee Pennsylvania New Jersey
Kentucky in New York should we rename
those towns how about Jefferson counties
should we rename Jefferson County
Alabama Arkansas Colorado Iowa Indiana
Kentucky Missouri Montana New York Ohio
Oklahoma Pennsylvania Tennessee
Washington West Virginia and Louisiana
maybe we'll do that huh how about the
Jefferson Memorial he's saying we
shouldn't memorialize Thomas Jefferson
because that gives him honor so I guess
we got a knock down the Jefferson
Memorial in DC how about other guys who
held slaves who were founding fathers
like I don't know George Washington
should we now rename the capital of our
country Washington DC we're not gonna
wipe Washington out of the history books
we'll still let him be in those books
and nobody's gonna read the books we
just aren't going to name things after
him because that gives him too much
honor and we shouldn't allow people who
held slaves to have any honor so we have
to rename Washington DC hi I'm Mayor
Pete I'm gonna mainstream the Democrat
Party by calling to rename Washington DC
have at the state of Washington
Washington's also a state Budaj edge is
asking he's raising a good question his
question is what is our relationship to
history what's our what's the
relationship of the past to the present
he's
giving the worst possible answer and the
most radical answer that has ever been
given in the history of the United
States good old mayor Pete mainstream in
the Democrat Party but what is our
relationship to our history do we hate
our history do we like our history do we
want to preserve our history do we even
know our history a culture that forgets
its past loses its identity this is what
the left wants this is why the left is
always fighting against history this is
why the left is always trying to get us
to undo our history these are the stakes
that we've got renaming Washington DC is
the not very far off logical conclusion
of what mayor Pete is saying and the
right is insufficiently aware of these
stakes this is not a normal election we
are not in normal times I know they say
this about every election but we really
aren't the eraser of history is not
normal the call to radically overhaul
the economy the transportation the
energy industry all of American housing
that's in the green New Deal virtually
every Democrat has endorsed it hundred
trillion dollar program that would knock
down your home and every other building
in the country and erase 90% of the
American energy industry and radically
redistribute wealth
that's not normal culturally calling men
women and women men is not normal
there's a story and now that a baby was
just killed because a man went into the
hospital with abdominal pains and he
said hey I'm a man and so they treated
him as though he were a man and then he
gave birth to a stillborn child because
he's not a man he's a woman and the the
disappeared in a medical journal they
insisted on referring to him or
assistant insisted on referring to her
as him they insisted referring to this
woman as a man and they said see this
brings up the stakes our medical
professionals really need to understand
that men can be pregnant men can't be
pregnant saying that we should pump
little boys full of hormones to make
them look more like little girls is not
normal Ernest Hemingway when he talks
about bankruptcy he says says how does
bankruptcy happen it happens gradually
then suddenly that's what we're seeing
we're seeing left-left ISM has happened
gradually for a hundred years now it's
happening suddenly and some
conservatives are whistling past the
graveyard
like this empty head Justin Amash the
Michigan congressman is a libertarian
Republican he is calling for Donald
Trump to be impeached why you ask well
he's highlighting the divide right now
on the right there is a major divide on
the right and what the with the people
like Justin Amash I don't even know to
pronounce his name Amash a mash a mesh I
don't know what people like him in his
side the ones who are highly irreparably
critical of the president what they are
advocating is a perfectly abstract
conservatism but there's what they're
saying the divide is between is between
the good people who have universal
values and then all the bad awful
bigoted terrible people that's that's
kind of how they're portraying it now
the mainstream media is portraying it
that way too that's not really what's
happening the the actual divide is
between a conservatism that is rooted in
something tangible and a conservatism
that is primarily if not purely abstract
that's that's the distinction and Justin
a mash is showing this so he sent out a
13 tweet long thread explaining why
Donald Trump should be impeached he
wrote here are my principal conclusions
Attorney General bar has deliberately
misrepresented Muller's report President
Trump is engaged in teachable conduct
partisanship has he wrote at our system
of checks and balances few members of
Congress have read the report next week
I offer these conclusions only after
having read Mulder's redacted report
carefully and completely having read or
watched pertinent statements and
testimony and having discussed this
matter with my staff who thoroughly
reviewed materials and provided me with
further analysis next week in comparing
bars principled conclusions
congressional testimony and other
statements to Muller's report it is
clear that Barr intended to mislead the
public about Special Counsel
Robert Muller's analysis and findings
next week bars misrepresentations are
significant but often subtle frequently
taking the form of slate of hand
qualifications or logical fallacies
which he hopes people will not notice
there are many many more tweets
you're still awake I'll point something
out to you 13 tweets long 494 words did
you notice what was missing from those
all of those tweets he never once gives
an example of a live from William bar or
a crime committed by Donald Trump he
goes on he talks about Oh
our beautiful Constitution the rule of
law the rule of law is being lost we
have to read the report we have to see
the conclusions the institutions depend
at bla bla bla bla bla if you're making
an allegation which is that AG bar lied
and Donald Trump committed a crime
worthy of impeachment cite the crime put
up or shut up but he doesn't he blathers
on and on and on for almost 500 words
it's the length of an op-ed in a lot of
outlets and yet he never actually points
it out because it doesn't matter this is
the purely abstract conservatism it's no
coincidence that Justin Amash would
consider himself really a libertarian
here are the aspects of this purely
abstract conservatism it's always
sanctimonious and it's always
holier-than-thou and the people who are
articulating it are always morally
perfect and the people they're talking
about are always the worst of the worst
and they're always assuming the worst
intentions the other aspect of it is
that it's very whiny it because it never
jives with reality so it's wham wham wow
we've got a impeach Trump oh it's so bad
or institutions why why why why why it's
really really why he doesn't offer any
practical solutions we all want to
change aspects of our culture in our
politics it doesn't offer really
tangible things you can hold on to it's
just why Iowa everything's so bad and
then finally the key aspect is it's
vague he never cites any concrete
example Roger Kimball had a tremendous
column at American greatness over the
weekend where he explained this divide
on the right as the great realignment
and he says it basically comes down to
two views of Liberty on the one hand
you've got conservatives who want to
conserve something on the other hand you
want you have conservatives who want to
affect this universal utopian vision
Roger writes quote the real battle that
has been
and it is a battle that is forging a
great political realignment is not
between virtuous progressive Knights
riding the steeds of liberalism on the
one hand and the atavistic forces of
untutored darkness represented by
populism on the other the real battle is
between two views of Liberty one is a
parochial view that affirms tradition
local affection and the subordination of
politics to the ordinary business of
life the other is more ambitious but
more abstract it seeks nothing less than
to boost us all up to that plane of
enlightenment from which all
self-interested actions look petty if
not criminal and through which mankind
as a whole but not alas individual men
may hope for whatever salvation
secularism leavened by utilitarianism
may provide that's the distinction
a conservatism that seeks to conserve
something and that seeks to conserve
ideas as they have been embodied to
conserve Liberty as has as our
traditional our political tradition has
embodied Liberty to preserve our Bott
bonds of love and kinship between our
neighbors and each other in our
countrymen and our loyalty to the
country that's one version the other
version is just this totally abstract
sanctimonious holier-than-thou
conservatism which isn't really
conserving anything at all it's just
bringing about a utopian vision of what
the perfect political order would look
like in that in those terms that kind of
conservatism quote unquote sounds a lot
like leftism it sounds just as utopian I
think that's the big difference and
you're seeing this play out in Australia
in the United Kingdom even in the u.s.
in Australia the can the mainstream
media and the experts were shocked
because the conservative prime minister
Scott Morrison won in his election why
did he win everyone thought the left
winner was gonna win it's because the
left was running on the green new deal
and the whole world in this perfect
order and the conservative guy was
running on our economy and keeping our
affairs as we like them and and and
keeping things roughly as they are
getting better over time but but
maintaining our identity as Australia in
the United Kingdom right now it looks
like Teresa
may the conservative Prime Minister is
going to get thrown out because the
Conservatives and labor both are not
supporting brexit and you've got Nigel
Farage who has the brexit party the
brexit party is surging in the elections
is it conservative is it liberal is it
no it's it is literally conservative
it's trying to conserve Britain and
Britain's political independence and
Britain's political traditions and what
makes Britain Britain same thing is
happening in the United States Donald
Trump won in 2016
why how did that happen why are people
still supporting Donald what did he run
on he ran on America first protect our
country not racism not sexism not
misogyny didn't run on those things he
ran on keeping America America allowing
America to be America again that's
there's not a there's not a totally
abstract government policy for
everything sometimes we just want to
conserve who we are but it brings me
we'll get to it and just this last
minute here to this revenge porn story
there's a story that just came out I
know it doesn't sound connected but it
actually is there's this story of okay
guys living with this girl and then
they're engaged to be married and he
starts having an affair with the
neighbor the fiancee finds that she
calls off the wedding obviously this is
not an amicable breakup and so because
they shared an iCloud account on their
iPhones this jilted woman can see all of
the texts that her fiance was getting
and some of them were a little saucy
from this neighbor girl
so what the jilted woman does is she
exposes the texts sends them to all of
their friends they see what a see what a
schmuck this guy is now there's a big
case is revenge porn protected by the
First Amendment is it constitutional
what government policy can we have to
look ladies here's I certainly seems
like this jilted woman acted within her
rights I don't think there's some law
against her exposing what a Schmucker
her boyfriend is and how awful the
neighbor girl is either now revenge porn
is pretty bad you know you've taken a
kadosh and then they get exposed to
everybody when the relationship breaks
down there doesn't necessarily need to
be a government policy to stop them you
just need to
sending naked photos to each other how
stupid do you have to be don't send
naked photos everything you send over
the Internet is going to be published on
the cover of The New York Times think of
it that way there's not a government
policy for everything there's not a
utopian political solution there's not
an abstract right where you can discern
ah yes this is the perfect government
policy for revenge porn in 2019 that I
have deduced from my Universal set of
Rights No
don't be stupid don't don't cheat on
your wife or your fiancee and don't send
naked photos to and from your mistress
this I think this is this conservatism
that is now coming up it's being called
populism or nationalism or all these
things I think it's people just saying
we want reality we want to conserve the
things that we like about our place we
like our neighborhood we like our
friends we like America we like our
traditions we don't want to give all of
that up for the green New Deal
we don't want to give up our homes in
our cars empty American energy industry
and our jobs we don't want to knock it
all down for pure Universal abstraction
now some people like Justin Amash or
like some of the really rationalistic
dogmatic conservative ideologue types
they say here's the here's the 10-point
manifesto of conservatism that the
conservatism is not a manifesto you
can't put it into a manifesto it's about
conserving something that is what we're
talking about the voters in Australia
they wanted to conserve their good
economy they've got the best economic
run in the history of the world about 29
years and so when you look at these
polls you look at all the big crazy
plans that the left is proposing the
Democrats in 2020 the green New Deal
reparations free income free all these
things say oh they're leading in the
polls I don't I don't always buy the
polls I think there is a conservative
revolution maybe it's not ideological
maybe it's not dogmatic people want
reality they want to keep what they have
they like their country they don't want
to get rid of their history they don't
hate their history they have a sense of
gratitude toward their country I think
that's the new conservatism I think it's
a wonderful thing we've got a lot more
to get to but got to do it tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael knows this
is the Michael an old show I'll see you
then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dobkiss and directed by Mike
joiner
executive producer Jeremy Borah senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is mixed by
Dylan case hair and makeup is by Joshua
alvera
and our production assistant is Nick
Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19 today on the Ben Shapiro show
Iran's provocations escalate and
Democrats compete for attention